[Music]
a mexican mirror mary is an alligator
why
a mexican mayor
mary's an alligator in protest of a
same-sex marriage law that's coming into
play so he's trying to make some weird
theater
oh that's actually good yeah that sounds
really really weird i thought that was a
good guy no that was actually terrible
that's a horrible something more
realistic something more realistic is
the drug cartels have been getting
[ __ ] crazy
and the alligators are taking over the
sails so to make sure that there's peace
put on the turf they're doing it the old
school way which is piece by marriage
that's a more realistic answer that's
way better i just and a better answer
this is a very grounded theory i'm
curious to hear more obviously maybe he
lost his lucky gold watch
and he thinks that he thinks that the
alligator swallowed it
and he knows he cannot get alligator
from neverland so he's gonna have to
wait it out but you can't yeah so they
get married who knows when they digest
who knows like they're old [ __ ]
dinosaurs they might digest like a
hundred years do alligators poop
sometimes do alligators poop see that
look it up nobody knows maybe at the end
of their tail it comes out like
toothpaste yeah
i don't think i would like the
toothpaste yeah at the end of the tail
that sounds clean and disgusting at the
same time what's bigger crocodile or an
alligator alligator i looked it up i
think it's alligator as well
okay go with alligator answer that
makes me believe you truly i really
looked it up cause i was [ __ ]
confused one day and i was like how do
you tell these things apart so alligator
has a broader and more square snout yeah
and crocodiles are skinnier and i think
crocodiles you can see the bottom teeth
or something and the crop alligator you
can only see the top one does water
influence whether one is an alligator or
cocktail no because i thought one was
africa and one was like
like water there's american and african
american source rex or a saber-toothed
tiger trying to start distracted that's
correct do you think so because they got
this yeah but they got a big-ass mouth
they'll just go like this i think [ __ ]
it up [ __ ] it up you seen [ __ ] cats
though cats are wild all right so
there's a dude named victor hugo sosa
mayor of a southwestern mexican town
called san pedro juamez
showed his commitment to his culture by
marrying an alligator known as quote
little princess end quote as part of a
ritual that is supposed to bring
prosperity and abundance to the town so
it's a ritual so a lot of people marry
alligators
there's no bullying in this town is that
what you're saying
nobody gets bullied in this town and
that's the real problem that's what
happens when you let non-bullying go
rampant
non-bullying go rant ideas get checked
it's like weeds just [ __ ] growing all
over the stupid ideas everywhere a
little bit of bullying will go along
it's gonna help a lot it'll save a
culture but not online because that's
not cool
what it has to be face to face it
depends because that's real that's real
yeah that's real
online bullying online is yeah that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you bully yourself do all
that's what i do
i want to know how they consummate this
marriage i don't know like you you're
wondering if they had sex that night for
pregnancy
uh i'll get to that in literally
that's the juicy decision just give some
backstory since visualize it the
alligator probably got cold [ __ ] too
cold-blooded cold [ __ ] coming out of
your mouth right it just makes me it's
around i don't want to assume the gender
bar it's a reptile he's like yo the hell
they're gonna got some cold water
the mayor's not assuming the gender
should be fine so why should we i just
know how reptiles work maybe the mayor
is the girl um [ __ ] yeah
his name is vince vince yeah victor hugo
victor
since pre-hispanic times indigenous
villagers in this town have believed
that the alligator represents a deity
and that the marriage between this
earthly god and their leader will bring
about an abundance of resources to
support the local fishing industry
is the alligator wearing a bride gown or
not yes that's the real question with
the veil
i need to know if that's happening does
she have a necklace on with the with
with the garner belt or
what no way why
you damn oh
you shall receive that is incredible
who's on the floor is incredible
damn son what's this town doing they're
trolling bro come on go buy a lottery
ticket steve it's rolling dude
together too
i love that you're like oh [ __ ] this is
real i can't believe that [ __ ] is real
they didn't want her to complain yeah
that's true that's why they tied her
mouth she's a latina [ __ ] complain
all day but it but it's but it's the
it's the wedding that she's always
wanted though you know like this is her
dream [ __ ] way
yeah dude but they didn't want her to be
bridezilla that day i thought it'd be
swampier but it's fine
it's good
with this belief firmly at the center of
the community mr sosa took the leap and
married little princess in a lavish
service that was accompanied by dancers
and ceremonial songs along with the
indigenous traditions catholic ones were
also incorporated the small alligator
was dressed in white among other colors
with an accompanying veil that was swept
away with her tightly tied can i be
honest absolutely i don't think she had
any business wearing white for that
what do you think it should have been
any [ __ ] because he knows her history
that's why come on dude hussy look at
that [ __ ] alligator look at that
hussy dog hey guess what
alligator every dude in that room is
like yeah okay you're lucky you're a
lucky man let's see how long this last
yeah he's like yeah we've all been there
done that
turn with miss alligator we got so much
fish in the [ __ ] sea huh exactly
he's like yeah you had to get stuck with
it we got to have fun with it yeah yeah
they showed a real good time prior this
alligator was baptized
oh good as part of the catholic you can
only marry a christian [ __ ] shame
it's an all steve day article and you
stole it from me like this
you just you just jealous my article
right yeah i am i actually i saw this
this is a yearly occurrence in the town
of san pedro juamez with every new mayor
required to marry a budding alligator
you have a new mayor every year
alligator beam
like a [ __ ] virgin probably a
blushing bride to be dude yeah what are
you talking about what the people at the
party were saying they got to do tests
you know and you make sure the blood is
there a quinceanera alligator like a 15
year old or something a ripe alligator
is there a first dance
that's what i was thinking how the [ __ ]
are they gonna dance but they're
literally no they just they just untie
her mouth and they he just tries to get
away from him
that's a good dance
that's a real good dance that's the
dance of marriage as one would say
forever
so let me guess with this idea let me
guess the article doesn't say anything
about alligator [ __ ] nope actually
right here yes it does the juicy part
let's go they gotta get those four guys
from india to show them how it's done oh
no they talk about how her dad's there
except he's in the form of boots
[Laughter]
she walked down the aisle
hey
that's good imagine like he's like
walking down the aisle in those houses
here
just so insensitive at eye level with
the alligator with the eyeballs on each
other she's like wow my dad's here is
crazy okay i haven't seen him in years
oh my god and there's two of them i
didn't think he was gonna show
up would you guys wear alligator
nah
why for what what what's the occasion i
don't know if i'm an animal kind of guy
a wedding yeah a mexican win
your wedding
makes you winning yeah i'll do a whole
suit and the shoes oh jesus christ
you're going to kill a whole ecosystem
nowhere it's been dead joe got alligator
it's been dead
i don't know i'm in my mind i'm thinking
yo they harvested the meat
they made some alligator sausages don't
throw away the skin bro you're gonna
ethically source your your alligator
the cowhide it's like if it's
if it's dead anyway you guys on the
brand tag label it's just like we needed
the meat
okay dude
don't throw away the skin that's gonna
be my tagline don't throw it away use it
this is good that's good that's kind of
good it's kind of it's kind of fire
actually yeah right
you're gonna eat that
you can eat that yeah
earlier this year a british woman is
busting uh
it is blessing uh
earlier this year a british woman
married her tuxedo cat called india in
an effort to ensure that she could not
be kicked out of her rental for having a
pet what so it's like it's not a pet
it's my husband and they'll recognize
that they'll recognize the marriage
between you and your cat i think
everything is allowed at least once
right hey look at um u.s states that
allow marrying animals
there's certain states feel like it's
just going to be along this out there
might be like at least three of them i
think yeah the purpose of marrying an
animal
it just sounds funny even i say that
together i think to consummate yeah
so you could [ __ ] your donkey without
shame dude
yeah if you do it outside of marriage
it's a sin yeah
you're talking to good christians here
dude you're making your donkey an honest
donkey can you can you google that
what's the point of marrying an animal i
don't know about what there's obviously
a point we're gonna we're gonna go past
this because if there is on me i will
say on the question of can you legally
marry an animal in america because it's
very important for all of our fans of
yours i'm glad anthony looked this up on
his computer by the way human animal
marriage is not specifically mentioned
in national laws that mean technically
there's nothing to stop it's a gray area
a human family an animal that's good
that's a good thing i think okay it
should be great so it sounds great in 50
states yeah
yeah human animal marriage is often seen
in accordance with zoophilia although
they are not necessarily linked so
technically that's good not necessarily
linked yeah what does that mean i don't
know
it means that all the people aren't
[ __ ] their married to an animal
doesn't mean you [ __ ] yeah engaging
in sexual acts is not the same as
finding your true love hey dude getting
married i don't know about you guys but
i've had i've never had less sex in my
life
rodney dangerfield showed up
whoa whoa whoa wait yeah potentially to
still reinstitute that corner cam that
gets the high fives i know the high five
cam quarter cam has to be here because
there's a lot of high fives that just
prepped me i'll [ __ ] record it on my
phone
people are missing all the fun oh wait
high five cam ready let's go people are
missing the fives and it's just it's
devastating the channel that's dead it's
devastating the channel so we lost so
many subscribers yeah dude they're like
i can't even see the high fives we'll
never get to two million because the
[ __ ] high fives
[Music]
hey
[Music]